يعني ربما منذ الحادي عشر من ديسمبر
الفائد كان كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد قال
انه بلغ مرحله استهداف القيادات
العليا في في حركه حماس لم يتمكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال في غزه من
الوصول الى اهداف لحركه حماس اهداف كبيره
لحركه حماس
لكن اغتيال العاروري جاء بعد بعد اكثر من
20 يوما من هذا الاعلان في اي اطار يمكن
تصنيفه وايضا رد الفعل المت وقع
هنا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولجمهور المشاهدين والمستمعين يعني في
الحقيقه هي بحث عن صوره انتصار عندما
تابعنا الاعلام العبري منذ الاعلان عن
عمليه الاغتيال والاعلام العبري يحتفي
بهذا الانجاز وكانه حصل نصف الحرب
وبالتالي العمليه العسكريه في غزه وصلت
الى طريق مسدود الاحتلال عاجز عن تحرير
المختطفين عاجز عن اغت القيادات كبرى في
المقاومه وعاج وعاجز عن كسر القوه
الاساسيه للمقاومه وبالتالي نتنياهو كان
يائس لاي صوره انتصار مهما كانت الان تم
اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري الشيخ صالح
العاروري كان يتنقل بحريه وبشكل طبيعي
داخل الضاحيه الجنوبيه بحكم ان قواعد
الاشتباك التي كان معمول بها لن تمس
الضاحيه ولن تمس بيروت وبالتالي كان
بمثابه هدف سهل للاحتلال
وايضا الشيخ صالح وجه يعرف الشارع
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اصبح هنا صوره انتصار
نتنياهو اراد من خلال هذه الضربه ان يقوم
بعده اشياء الشيء الاول ان يحرج حزب الله
بشكل كبير جدا كون الضربه لم تستهدف شخصيه
لبنانيه لكن استهدفت شخصيه فلسطينيه على
الاراضي اللبنانيه ومرتبطه في الحرب في
غزه فهذا عقد الوضع بالنسبه لحزب الله
وايضا الامر الاخر اخر هو نقل قواعد
الاشتباك الى بيروت الان ليس الموضوع ايضا
موضوع اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري الموضوع
هو ان بيروت على المحك بمعنى انه اذا حزب
الله مرر هذه الضربه او لم يكن الرد عليها
يعني رد لا يقبل الجدل ويحقق الردع ستتحول
بيروت تدريجيا الى دمشق اخرى بمعنى
الغارات الاسرائيليه المستمره ستكون عليها
اسبوعيا وشهريا وربما على مدار اليوم
وبالتالي هذه صوره معقده جدا الان ما الذي
يمكن ان يرد ان يرده حزب الله هل سيتجه
حزب الله الى حرب مفتوحه ويبادر هو
بالضربه لا لكن على الاغلب سيوجه ضربه
قاسيه الى اسرائيل هذه الضربه ربما تكون
قصف حقل كاريش او الحقل حقل الغاز الموجود
قباله سواحل لبنان الذي من فتره اعلن
الاحتلال بان هناك مسيره استهدفت هذا
الحقل وتم اسقاطها لكن حزب الله يمتلك
صواريخ ارض بحر ربما قادره هي صواريخ
الياخن الروسيه قادره على اصابه وتدمير
هذا الحقل وبالتالي هل معنى ذلك اسمح لي
سييد ع الع س هل معنى ذلك اننا قد نتوقع
من يعني الامين العام لحزب الله حسن نصر
الله يوم غد في الكلمه المرتقبه اي رد فعل
في هذا الاطار
محدد يعني يمكن ان يستخدم اذا كان المقصود
هنا ضرب حقل كاريش يعني يمكن ان يستخدم
وان يعيد الى اذهان حرب لبنان العام 2006
عندما كان في خطابه وقال انظروا الى
السفينه خود حنيت البارجه الاسرائيليه وهي
تحترق وفعلا ضربت بصواريخ ارض بحر يمكن ان
يستخدم ذات الاسلوب وان يضرب حق ال كريش
في اثناء خطابه هذا وارد ووارد جدا يمكن
ان يضرب معسكر كبير في الشمال ضربه تكون
قاضيه بمعنى اطلاق صليه من صواريخ بركان
او الصواريخ الثقيله ضمن مساحه الاشتباك
في الشمال وبالتالي توقع اضرار كبيره جدا
واعداد كبيره من ال القتلى الجنود تكون
يعني بمثابه رساله ردع الى اسرائيل لكن
ايه الاشكاليه هنا الان بان
اي هذه الضربه يجب ان تكون مؤلمه ورادع
لاسرائيل لانها اذا لم تكن رادعه سيخرج
نتنياهو وسيخرج الاعلام العبري ويقول هذه
الضربه كانت متوقعه ومستعدين ان نحن يعني
استوعبنا في اطار الهدف الكبير الذي
حققناه وهو اغتيال الشيخ صالح العاروري
وبالتالي الان توازنات حزب الله دقيقه جدا
وربما تاخر حزب الله في الرد وهو هذا امر
اخطر ايضا بانه يشاور حلفاء الاقليميين
بمعنى انه الان اجرى مشاورات مع طهران
اجرى مشاورات مع الحوثيين اجرى مشاورات مع
الجماعات العراقيه المواليه لايران اذا
كنا نتحدث عن حرب اقليميه او عن رد موسع